hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
diabetes and the clinical laboratory i
am jennifer woods of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott diagnostic
to learn more visit abbott.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker professor
w
gary john consultant in clinical
biochemistry norfolk and norwich
university hospital
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr john you may now begin your
presentation
jennifer thank you for that nice
introduction ladies and gentlemen
i'm going to talk today about diabetes
and the clinical laboratory so let's
first look at diabetes
diabetes has been with us for many many
years
indeed we can look at this papyrus from
ancient egypt
dating back to 1500
bc where the text describes the classic
symptoms
of polyuria seen with diabetes
coming forward to the 1600s a biochemist
and physician
called willis described the urine of
diabetics
as having a sweet taste and of course he
knew
that he's a biochemist because he
associated this with
guzzling down of wine but urine became a
very important part in identifying
diabetics
for many many years but what is diabetes
well in 1980 the whole expert committee
on diabetes
described it as a state of chronic
hypoglycemia
a very broad description
in 1997 this is further
refined by the ada expert committee
as a group of metabolic diseases
characterized by
hyperglycemia resulting from
defects in insulin secretion insulin
action
or both and overall this this
description is still widely used today
but what is hyperglycemia the number of
variables affect the glucose
concentration
the population in which we are looking
different populations have different
reference ranges for glucose
fasting and fasting and feeding however
have an effect on the glucose result as
does age
sample type and analytical method
so we need to ask ourselves what is
hyperglycemia and we may come back to
that a little later on
so diabetes there are a number of
different types of diabetes
let's look at them individually type 1
diabetes mellitus
this is due to autoimmune destruction of
the beta cells
of the ils of langerhans
this results in insulin deficiency
and eventually a lifelong dependence
on insulin injections
this is due to the beta cell destruction
which is a slow
and progressive process taken several
years
to finally complete
whereas the clinical onset of diabetes
is abrupt
usually measured in weeks so you get
this destruction happening for a long
time
and then certainly the individual
becomes diabetic
and men in many cases the first sign
is actual presentation into a and e
with ketoacidosis and hyperglycemia
there are a number of markers of
developing type 1 diabetes
the appearance of glutamic acid
decarboxylase
lsl auto antibodies and insulin auto
antibodies
and these can be detected 10 to 15 years
before the onset of the disease itself
but it's worth noting that not everybody
who has these auto antibodies
go on to develop type 1 diabetes
although the chances
increase the more of the auto antibodies
you actually have
unlike type 1 diabetes type 2 diabetes
has an etiology which is unknown
it is a defect in innocent secretion and
or insulin action
and the disease itself is likely to be
polygenic
it is a group of disorders that is
characterized
by the development of hypoglycemia
the vast majority of patients have some
degree of insulin resistance
but instant resistance itself does not
cause
type 2 diabetes which only manifests
it is a coexistence of innocent
secretary defect
now type 2 diabetes accounts is the most
common form of diabetes
around 90 percent of all diabetic cases
are type 2 diabetes
and it is the most common non-commutable
disease
in the world it is predicted that over
half the patients will live in asia
type 2 diabetes commonly found in the
older individual
adults but unfortunately is increasingly
being seen
in children adolescents and younger
adults
is it due to the rise of level of
obesity
the decrease in physical activity and
poor diet found
in these younger individuals
you can see here the relationship
between obesity
and type 2 diabetes we can see that
as body mass index increases
so does the rate of type 2 diabetes
both in women and in men
so you can see straight away that
obesity
is directly related to the development
of diabetes
if you look at the picture of diabetes
around the world
in 2000 the global estimate of adults
living with diabetes
was 151 million people
a big number in its own right alice
predicted in 2010
that the global projection for diabetes
by 2025
would be 438 million
now in 2020 with five years still to go
that prediction has been surpassed
by 25 million individuals today we
calculate
463 million people are living with
diabetes
9.3 percent of the ideal population
between the age of 20 and 79 years of
age
at a further 1.1 million under 20
living with type 1 diabetes
the idf estimates international diabetes
federation estimates there will be 578
million adults
with diabetes by 2030
and an unbelievable 700 million
by 20-45 numbers you can hardly believe
can exist
the next type of diabetes of course is
gestational diabetes and this
occurred during pregnancy
gestational diabetes is hypoglycemia
during pregnancy
with blood glucose values above what is
normally found
but below those diagnostic diabetes
women with gestation diabetes are
increased risks of complications during
pregnancy
and also mainly at delivery
now these women and possibly the
children are also at increased risk
of developing type 2 diabetes in the
future
there are a number of other types of
diabetes describe the whole
but probably the most interesting one
here is maturity onset diabetes of the
young
this is an increasing disease population
as more and more people we thought as
young individuals with type 1 actually
modi the maturity onset non-innocent
diabetics
so let's look here this is young leonard
thompson
who at 14 years of age was the first
patient
to receive insulin on january 11 1922
at this point in time he had a very very
high
blood glucose i was urinating about five
liters a day
he was only kept alive on a low calorie
diet
with low carbohydrates because before
this time
we had no means of treating our patients
with type 1 diabetes
and they would die at a very early age
luckily two canadians charles best and
frederick branding
discovered the use of insulin and
actually uses insulin to treat
a diabetic dog now we remember
best and bunting but who remembers the
dog
what was the dog's name well this most
important person
was called marjorie remember that
best bunting at marjory
so this is young leonard thompson 12
months after
first treated with insulin we can now
see that he is a well individual
slightly overweight maybe
and that was a new challenge we had new
challenge was to how to control
the glycemia in our patients with
diabetes
and prevent the complications associated
with long-term
hyperglycemia
this is where the clinical laboratory
comes into the story
and for many years it did in back as far
as the 1900s
the only thing we had to offer was
glucose
we could measure glucose ranging from
very early tests for glucose
to present day enzymatic methods
but we've seen this slide already what
is hyperglycemia
when measured using glucose there's a
whole range of different things affect
the glucose and volume
even samples collected will lose glucose
concentration
from them after collecting from the arm
glucose concentrations are lost from the
glucose sample
even if we use uh anticoagulant
with a material to stop the glucose
being lost
fluid oxalate is commonly used you can
see here in this slide
that even with fluid oxalate in the
sample
over the course of the first one to one
and a half hours following collection
glucose concentrations are lost from the
sample
at about the same rate as if no
glucose blocker was actually used after
about one half hours
the glucose loss is stopped whereas if
there's no glucose blocker
then it actually carries on we can see
here
glucose results in our samples
are dependent on what is what the
collection material is
and length of time after collection
so using glucose for assess glycemia was
a problem
we needed something new
luckily in 1968
a researcher called rubber who's looking
at the red cells
of from patients with diabetes
described what he called as an
abnormal fast-moving hemoglobin
we now know of course this abnormal
hemoglobin is not abnormal
but it's glycated hemoglobin
now what is glycated hemoglobin well you
may have seen some slides
showing the formation of glycemic
globulin but
it's not quite as straightforward as
that let's go through this
slowly
glucose as long as it's in the open
chain
format will react with all proteins in
the body
the glucose will bind preferentially
in most proteins the lysine residue
hemoglobin is unique in that the glucose
in the hemoglobin molecule
binds to the n terminal valine
but not only if the glucose is in the
open chain format
if it isn't a ringing structure it does
not react
glucose binds in this readily reversible
reaction
forming a shift base or aldemine
this shift base will then undergo an
almost irreversible almond dual
rearrangement where the double bond
moves from position number one
to position number two thereby
stabilizing
this fraction again
if the ring for forms of glucose happens
the reaction does not happen itself
so the overall reaction takes place in
two stages
the first is a reasonably reversible
reaction
which takes place over a number of hours
and thereby reflecting a hour by hour
change in a glycemia in the body
the second almost irreversible reaction
of all intensive purposes we can assume
this is non-reversible takes place over
several days
so the glucose levels have to be at a
certain concentration
to create this final ketoamine or
hemoglobin a1c
or glycated hemoglobin
the entire reaction follows the law of
mass action
the non-enzymatic reaction which
actually means
the more of the reactants there are
the more of the product is formed
so in a hemoglobin molecule this takes
place
over the life span of the red cell
and once this glycatid hemoglobin is
formed it remains
in place the life of that red cell
what period of time are we looking at it
is it is
thought that the glycae hemoglobin
hemoglobin a1c
reflects the previous three to four
months
of glycemia within the body
well that is true but overall
when we look at the results the sample
that we collect
reflects glycemia in the month
in which that sample is collected 52
of the result in that hemoglobin they
want to see
is based on the month in which the
sample is collected
only 27 of the effect of that result
is from the month before 14
for the month before that and only about
6 reflecting glycemia
four months before the sample so yes
overall
hemoglobin a1c does reflect glycemia
over the preceding three to four months
but the vast majority of the effect on
that result
is within the month of the sample being
collected
so we got we have hemoglobin a1c
so how are we going to measure it
well there are a number of method
principles we can use to measure
hemoglobin i want to see
if hemoglobin is glycated at the end
terminal valine
and only at the end terminal valine what
i forgot to say it will glycated other
parts
of the hemoglobin molecule if you glance
at the end terminal valine it creates a
very small
charge difference of course it creates a
structural difference and also a
chemical difference so let's look at
charge differences
probably the most recognizable method by
which you measure hemoglobin a1c
is cation exchange hplc
and there are a number of manufacturers
worldwide now
that that will sell you hplc
for cation separation
charge separation is also achieved using
capillary
electrophoresis this is a slower method
that creates a greater separation in the
peaks that you see
of hemoglobin a1 and hemoglobin a note
to achieve this throughput required
these capillaries
are run in parallel several at a time
structural differences affinity
chromatography
you can we can use bronic acid
here to bind the glucose moiety
of the hemoglobin glycolytic hemoglobin
it recognizes the cyst
dials on the glucose attached to the
protein
so this now measures all glycae
hemoglobins
hemoglobin glycates at the end terminal
valine angular hemoglobin glycated at
glycine residues
the glycation binds the bronic acid and
the non-glycated hemoglobin washes off
the column
we can then use a counter ligand to wash
off the glycated hemoglobin
and we can measure the color in the two
fractions and
calculate a percentage
immunoassay you can imagine how
difficult it was
to raise antibodies against heat
glucadimoglobin
where the main difference is glucose
moiety
nowadays there are number of amino acids
available which recognize three or four
amino acids
and the glucose attached to the end
terminal valine
chemical differences this is the newest
method available on the on the
market and this uses an enzymatic
method to recognize a dipeptide
the glucose attached to it and right and
converting that
fructose dipeptide to um
to h2o2 i measured it calorimetrically
this method can be used on a automated
analyzer
within the laboratory all methods
are actually extremely good
and provide a good outcome and would be
up to the laboratory which method they
choose
but if you're going to choose a method
then the thing we need to consider
is standardization let's look back to
when these first method these methods
first described
back in the early 70s and early 80s
things didn't look good for fashion back
in those days
but things look even worse for
hemoglobin a1c
this year shows the between a laboratory
agreement the hemoglobin may want to see
in a large region
within the uk and we can see between
laboratory cvs
about 30 what does that mean in reality
well it means if you went to one
laboratory and had your blood sample
measured for hemoglobin a1c
you could get a result of 4.3 percent
if you had the same blood sample
measured in another laboratory
you could get a result of 9.4 percent
this resulted in an almost unusable
method for diabetic control
no standardization you can see the same
thing
in the college american pathologist cap
scheme
where in 1993
results could vary between 7.5 percent
down to 2.5 percent on the same eqa
sample
no standardization
this lack of standardization led to a
number
of countries introducing national
standardization schemes
probably the most recognized one is a
national glycohemoglobin standardization
program
now called the ngsp
the problem with all these national
schemes
was there was a lack of a true reference
method
there's no primary refs material and no
traceability
but these harmonization schemes did work
and when we look at the cap scheme of
the 1990s and early
2000s we can see an improvement
in the target values being achieved
by different laboratories and this is a
result of
harmonization of these results
but the ifcc recognized that there's a
need
for global standardization of hemoglobin
a1c
if we to use this value nationally
internationally to set targets for
individuals
so working through the setup with
members from
north america from europe from asia and
from australia
it was my great pleasure to chair this
working group
and over the time period we actually
developed a reference method
based on methodological requirements
metallurgy requirements require you to
identify the measure and
what you are going to measure reference
procedures reference laboratories
reference materials and traceability
so let's look at the measurand
we decided that we would measure
hemoglobin
that is located at the n terminal valine
we will not include hemoglobin that was
glycated in other parts of the molecule
and the ifcc committee on
naming these compounds named it
hemoglobin
beta chain blood n one deoxy fructosyl
one aisle hemoglobin beta chain a
mouthful
you'll agree but you can call it
hemoglobin a1c
also at the metrological conditions we
should
report in s i units so the sr
unit for hemoglobin a1c is millimole
per mole that is millimole of hemoglobin
a1c
per mole of hemoglobin and not plus
hemoglobin a1 and c
the two fractions that you can measure
a reference motion procedure before you
have a reference method
you need to have standards so the first
thing we did
was to produce pure hemoglobin a1c
and pure hemoglobin a and naught these
are produced in very
very small milligram amounts but are
used
to standardize the reference method
the reference method is hplc mass
spectrometry
or http llc capillary electrophoresis
both methods give identical results and
are highly accurate
for measuring hemoglobin a1c
and following acceptance by all meth all
countries within the ifcc
is now recognized as the reference
procedure
for standardizing hemoglobin a1c
worldwide
reference laboratories we now have 18
laboratories
worldwide using this reference
measurement procedure
and when we assign calibrate values
standards results from all the reference
laboratories
are used to assign these values
and because the results from all is
about to use
this results in a high level of accuracy
we now have a means of which we can
assign values
to hemoglobin a1c by all commercial
methods
which are highly accurate
and traceability we can now trace
results
from the patient's sample through
unbroken chain of events
back to the primary reference material
this means that for now and for the
future
we know results will be the same and are
highly
accurate
we can see this now in later cap surveys
which show that we are now achieving
the right results for our hemoglobin a1c
and the variability around that result
is far tighter and because of this
we've seen the cap has less
of uh improved their acceptance criteria
from 15 back in 1996
to plus my six percent now and this can
be tightened
even further
so with calibration and standardization
of results how are we going to report
these results worldwide
in 2007 the
american diabetes association the
european association studied diabetes
the international diabetes federation
and the ifcc
met to discuss how to report hemoglobin
a1c results
and the consensus was that the ifcc
reference system
female global a1c is the only
valid anchor to standardize this
measurement
and also hemoglobin a1c results should
be reported
worldwide in ifcc units or
more accurately si units at millimoles
per mole
and derived ngsp units percentages
okay so how we're going to use this to
monitor our patient with diabetes
well hemoglobin msc became important for
the publication of the dccct study the
diabetes
control and complications trial in type
1 diabetics
in america where we can see that as
hemoglobin a1c values increased
so did the rate of retinopathy
nephropathy
neuropathy and microarginuria
and the higher the value the greater the
increase
in these complications
we can also see from the uk pds
which is in type 2 diabetics that
a 1 decrease in hemoglobin
a1c or 10 millimole per mole decrease
resulted in a 21 decrease
in the deaths related to diabetes a 37
decrease in microvascular complications
and a 14 decrease in myocardial
infarctions
so a very small improvement in
hemoglobin a1c
resulted in vast improvements in outcome
so what assumptions we have to use if
we're going to
assume that hemoglobin a1c is a monitor
of glycemia
we have to assume that hemoglobin is
present at a constant concentration
we have to assume that the lifespan of
the red cell is a constant
but we assume that microenvironment is a
constant now this may be true in
individuals
but may not be true in the population as
a whole
but only if these are constant these
glucose become the only variable
and hemoglobin a1c represent glycemia
so what affects the hemoglobin a1c
result
the lifespan of the red cell has had an
effect on hemoglobin a1c result
and bob cohen looking at red cell life
spans
corrected values and could show that if
you
normalized the red cell to 120 days
you could normalize the hemoglobin on
the same
show very clearly that the lifespan of
the red cell had a direct effect
on hemoglobin a1c
ethnicity affects hemoglobin a1c
you can see here data from the diabetes
prevention program
that showed that the mean hemoglobin c
in subjects with impaired gluco
tolerance
was five point seven eight
for whites six percent for asians
and six point one eight percent for
blacks and this is after just if
anything that may affect glycemia age
sex blood pressure etc
so blacks have got a higher hemoglobin
a1c
than whites for the same level of
glycemia
age as we get older hemoglobin a1c
increases and this is independent of
glycemia
this is a study by david nathan and
co-workers
that showed independent of the level of
glucose hemoglobin a1c
levels increased decade upon decade
anemia and this affected him globally
want to see
this is a systematic review that a me
and a group of workers did
some years ago and showed that
anti-physicist anemia
and eye deficiency per se clearly have
an effect of increasing
hemoglobin a1c values probably because
red cell survival increases innocent
with iron deficiency anemia but
there is no clear cut point at which
anemia becomes a problem
non-eye deficiency anemia showed either
no chain hemoglobin a1c
or decreased values in the globe they
want to see
and the message here is knowing the
hemoglobin
level alone is insufficient to judge
whether the hemoglobin a1c is affected
or not
just quickly this is a very nice but
very small study done in 2004
where 50 patients with individual anemia
were compared to 50 controls
hemoglobin we see in a healthy group was
5.9
plus minus 0.5
in the iron deficiency anemia group it
was 7.4
plus or minus 0.8 and that was
significantly different
from the healthy group
this iron division name a group were
just treated with iron
nothing else just iron and three months
later the hemoglobin a1c fallen to 6.2
percent
which is not significantly different
from the healthy group
there are a large number of people with
iron deficiency anemia and we don't know
who they are
so we have to be careful
hemoglobin we see in diagnosis
we have already seen the large number of
patients with diabetes
but probably the most worrying thing is
that about 50 percent of people with
diabetes
are out in the population undiagnosed
so in 2011 the debris recommended that
hemoglobin a1c can be used for
diagnosing diabetes
i set a level of 6.5 percent of 48
millimoles per mole
as the diagnostic cut point for diabetes
but they went on to say that this level
does not exclude diabetes diagnosed with
glucose tests
so a 6.5 come from where it came from a
number of studies
the dtac 2 study mainly which showed
that as
hemoglobin values increased at level
above 6.5 percent there was an
inflection
in which the in which the level of
retinopathy
increased now there's a problem here
because this increase was an established
retinopathy
and wasn't based on things like
macrovascular complications
at 6.5 percent we've already got
an increase in the number of patients
we've shown
diabetes manifestations and increasing
cardiovascular disease
an increase in stroke and an increase in
total mortality
is 6.5 percent 48 millimole
the right value or isn't it
where did it come from as i said it
comes from the detect 2 study
but if you look closer you see that the
rock of analysis
shows it should be 6.4 percent
so why recommend 6.5 probably because
it is an easy number to remember
so what is diabetes that well diabetes
is a move
from normal glycemia through dysglycemia
into frank diabetes with an increasing
risk of cardiovascular disease
and microvascular complications
and we're diagnosing diabetes at this
point here
where cardiovascular disease and more
importantly probably microvascular
complications have already
increased and what we need to do is to
bring this diagnosis closer
now these hemoglobin a1c may help this
because we can screen and look for more
patients who probably have the disease
quality of results
the difference in diagnosis between
diabetes and low risk diabetes is only
seven millimost
more 0.7 percent methods have to be
highly accurate
to achieve this imprecision
again there's difference between
diabetes and low risk
we need cvs of our methods to be about
two percent
if they reach four percent then we can
overlap between these
two very different risk factors
so the ifcc task force which i shared
came up with recommendations using sigma
metrics
to actually identify quality in
hemoglobin a1c
and we suggested two sigma level
of quality at five millimoles per mole
so we had we had we looked at a bias
level of five millimole
and a cv of five percent
why five millions from all well this is
some work from earner lenders that
looked at asked
clinicians a question what do you
believe is a true
difference in hemoglobin a1c and they
said five millimost per mole
they believed the true difference
hemoglobin a1c
so we use this sigma metrics model in a
large european study
looking at 200 hundred certificates
throughout europe
and you can see that most laboratories
were actually coming within the sigma
metrics acceptable level
the important thing to note here is that
the bias is very small
showing a standardization has worked
but imprecision still leaves improvement
between laboratory agreement of
different methods
has got a little way to go here and
manufacturers
need to work on trying to improve this
imprecision
of agreement between laboratories
you can use this sigma metrics model on
the cap data
and we can see here back in 2014
the mean overall result was outside
except deliver
levels but in 2018 the mean result is
falls within
the acceptable levels how does this
happen well
poor performing methods have gone and
have been replaced with better
performing methods
and this is how we can use quality data
to move the
move quality onwards
so just to finish to be topical
let's look at hemoglobin a1c diabetes
and the corvid 19.
to my mind covert 19 in diabetes has two
effects
the social aspects we have seen a
problem with our patients now
because patients are not seeking medical
attention
they are not coming into clinics or
hospital
to have their diabetes looked at this
could have a long-term effect on the
control of the patient with diabetes
and the biological effective clinical
outcome itself directly related
to corvid even though we don't know what
this effect actually is
we are seeing what it looks like in the
systems
i just represent two studies to you from
uk and from this study we can see here
of inpatient deaths from a patient who
have shown be covered positive
we can see based on patients who are
non-diabetic
patients with both type 1 and type 2
diabetes
throughout the age range shows an
increased risk of
dying in hospital
based against people who are not
diabetic
you can see here at the oils ratio if
you're a diabetic
you're far more likely to die of our
following
disease following an infection with
corvid 19.
why is this well this other study looks
here
that diabetics as hemoglobin values
increase
your risk of dying increases and in type
1 diabetics it becomes significant at
this level
in type 2 diabetes you can see a
significant increase at a far lower
level as well
so patients who have got diabetes
unfortunately at
far higher risk of dying following
infection with corvette 19.
so hemoglobin we see in the future our
improved understanding of hemoglobin
energy measurements
and the better analytical methods we
have these days have enabled us to look
more focused on individuals
and individual treatment targets
so if you look at these different
conditions here some are modifiable and
others are not
modifiable let's look a bit more closely
at here
disease duration and life expectancy
because diabetic complications develop
over time
if we got a young newly diagnosed
diabetic
with a long lifespan in front of them we
want to be
more stringent over their control
if you assume seven percent or 53
millimole
as a target for con for treatment then
you want to get that
number lower if that patient has got a
long time to live
because they want to stop this
complications happening
if the patient is getting older
individual
long-standing diabetes you can be less
stringent with them
because they got less time to develop
the complications
and also their life is probably better
served
by giving a bit more freedom in what
they choose to do
so we now need we need to review our
diagnostic targets for diagnosis
based on ethnicity age etc
do we do do we need different diagnostic
targets for different ethnicities
and different ages we need to look at
screening for diabetes in different
populations
and hemoglobin a1c may have
a risk factor in the non-diabetic
population itself
such as cardiovascular disease so to
finish
if we look at the evolution of
hemoglobin clinical practice
it started off the discovery of a new
hemoglobin fraction
recognition in clinical medicine
the publication of the dcct and uk pds
in type 1 diabetes type 2 diabetes
giving us
a very clear understanding of hemoglobin
a1c as importance
in developing complications
standardization of the results globally
using ifcc standardization
this standardization allows us to set
targets for treatment
and allows us to actually use hemoglobin
and receive a diagnosis
and the recognition of individual
variation
because we can now measure this fraction
so well has allowed us to
start working towards individual
treatment goals
for our patients with diabetes
just to finish i'd just like to bring
your attention to the ifcc committee
for the education of youtube diabetes of
your biomarks and diabetes
this is an icc committee for education
in diabetes which i share and we have
other members from the uk
from japan america and the netherlands
and if you want to talk about diabetes
organize any educational symposia
or even if you wish some education
material
please contact us and we can help in any
way we can
thank you
thank you dr john for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
why do you think type 2 diabetes is not
commonly diagnosed in children
adolescents and younger adults
well there's probably a number of
reasons for this and part of the reasons
is until recently type 2 diabetes
was typically thought as a disease of
the older
middle age and elderly individual
and the un un recognized etiology
disease
i mean it's difficult including
clinically distinguishing
the diabetes in children and adolescents
uh and the lack of guidelines uh which
when to screen children
so our understanding now of
of diabetes in children is changing
dramatically
and also the obesity we now see in the
younger individual
it leads into us realizing that we can
be seeing type 2 diabetics
in these younger younger individuals
thank you dr john our second question
is there a link between obesity and
diabetes
yes i think so obesity is to be a key
factor to health
it's often related to a decrease in
physical activity
and we are seeing a remarkable increase
in obesity across the age ranges
across all different ethnicities the
raise in type 2 diabetes rate
mirrors its growth in urbanization
and economic development overweight and
obesity have become
major problems in adolescence around the
world
there's no hardly a country in the world
there's no
not suffering from this pandemic
of obesity
all right thank you we have another
question do you believe there's room for
improvement
in analytical quality yes i think so
from the slides we saw from the euro a1c
study
we have we have seen the standardization
has resulted in overall improvement in
the accuracy
with major manufacturers achieving
values well within buyers targets
and this has been a huge uh success
for standardization only on a huge um
sort of improvement in the situation
which i'm very pleased to have been
involved with
but there's improvement to be made in
the between laboratory agreement
of results in precision as a liquid way
to go
and manufacturers are now working very
hard to try and improve the situation
so accuracy bias as a as
very very good outcome it needs to be
improvement in imprecision
okay thank you again dr john our next
question
of the three detection methods discussed
for separation of hemoglobin a1c
charge structure or chemical differences
is there a preferred detection method to
detect hemoglobin a1c
i think here laboratories need to select
the method they wish to use based on
the the quality of the method they've
got standardization the method
and precision and accuracy of that
method um
most manufactured methods that we have
available in the clinical laboratory
are actually extremely good but there
are some methods out there which
which probably don't work as well as
others so you've got to decide
yourself in your laboratory
what is right for you the choice of
detection method is less important
than the quality of the result is giving
you
so you need to actually decide as a
laboratory director or the scientist
within that section
as to what is important to your
laboratory
and what is the method that gives the
best results
in your particular dream
okay i've got time for one more question
do you feel that individualized
treatment plans will lead to better
outcomes for patients with diabetes than
trying to get everyone to below 48
millimoles per mole per six and a half
percent hba1c
yeah individual treatment plans will
lead to better outcomes
for individuals target values are based
on population
rather than individuals for older people
who are likely to have other medical
issues
the goal should be to lower the
hemoglobin a1c to a level
which is suitable for them
maybe seven percent 53 millimeters or
more
maybe it's not it yeah
and you shouldn't be aggressively
treating them to lower the values than
to say 40 ml
small 6.5 percent when it possibly is
causing them more harm
and by harm i mean harm to themselves as
individuals
rather than harm in terms of
complications people
who are older
need to be given a bit more freedom of
life whereas if you're a younger
individual
with a long term uh to live with
with diabetes and the complication it
might bring
you want to be a bit more stringent with
them but
the the thing we have learned over the
last few years
with diabetes is that you should be
individualizing
this treatment to the person themselves
and not to an overall treatment goal
based on population
thank you dr john do you have any final
comments for our audience
i think basically hemoglobin a1c
is a tool which is now standardized
worldwide
we know what the what the limitations of
the method are
we have we can devise guidelines
for our patients individualized to into
the individual patient and we can set
our diagnostic categories to identify
these patients
hopefully quicker than we have done in
the past
so we can get on top of this disease and
control it because there is going to be
increasing numbers of patients with
diabetes
in the world in the coming years
well thank you again dr john for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye